hello everyone it's October 2nd 2017 and
this is going to be by far the absolute
most busy month of the year for me so
I've got to get this in while I can this
is my monthly update video I'm going to
tell you about what went on in September
which was pretty busy and what we've got
lined up for October which is going to
be incredibly packed a lot of really
cool stuff going on I always like to
begin by talking about three big things
that I want to highlight all three of
them this month for reasons that I think
you can understand have to do with
stoicism so I'm gonna lay those out at
the very beginning so the big thing
number one is that I'm going to be at
stoic on and stoic on Ex Toronto I won't
be presenting at stoic context I'll just
be attending which is kind of fun for me
but I will be providing a workshop with
Andy Shaka my wife and partner on
dealing with with difficult people at
work some stoic strategies and practices
that can help out with that I think
that's probably a very timely topic and
I may in fact be doing some other things
while I'm there so if you're at stoic on
in Toronto make sure to stop by and say
hello introduce yourself and I can't
promise that I'll have lots of time to
chat but but you know I'll certainly try
to make some time the big thing number
two is that we have some stoic week
events both here in Milwaukee and I'll
also be at one down in Chicago so I'll
talk about that in the October part of
this and the third thing really big is
I'm going to be having a number of
Stoicism themed online events for
various people the this offers viewers
subscribers interests of people
worldwide a chance to hear some
interesting stuff and in many cases
interact with me directly about stoicism
so those are the three big things
for this month you can you know look
down below and you're gonna see links to
all of these so you probably want to
check them out so I mentioned that
September was a pretty busy month
October is gonna be even busier but but
there was a lot that went on I just
finished doing my very first online AMA
that's ask me anything session using
YouTube live you can see the video
linked below I did that as kind of a
reward once I reached a certain level of
monthly patreon support the $250 a month
level and once they reached the $500
level I'm going to do those AMA sessions
monthly anybody can ask me anything they
want as it turned out most people ask me
stuff about philosophy although I did
get one question about heavy metal which
was was pretty good so that is is a big
new development we also we had another
really cool online event we had our
Hegel party celebrating a milestone the
the other things that we did you know I
continued my worlds of speculative
fiction philosophical themes series and
we talked about William Gibson's sprawl
trilogy you know the sort of origin of
cyberpunk that was really fun session a
lot of good discussion I'd like to
revisit Gibson sometime we did some
philosophy pop ups which you can see the
videos for stoicism and what in
accordance with nature means we also did
some webinars and seminars on Plato love
sex politics in the symposium I can see
the video for the webinar link to below
and I did some podcast guest appearances
I'm not actually podcasting myself
although that's also tied to patreon if
you want to see me podcasting you
probably want to start contributing on
patreon because that's a huge investment
of time on my part I am appearing on
other people's podcasts though so I was
on philosophy bakes bread both in a
major segment and also in what they call
a
bread crumb of the major segments
talking about you know my work online
and how I got into YouTube the half hour
Hagel series public philosophy in
general and the bread crumb thing
specifically about stoicism the Thom
Ritchie podcast I appeared on that
talking with him about the Confederate
statues controversy a lot of really
great discussion there by the way if
you're interested in having me on a
podcast I've become kind of a regular at
first I was you know the side note it
was very nervous and over prepared for
podcasts now you know sort of take it as
a matter of course and I really enjoyed
doing it so if you want me on your
podcast just email me Greg at reason IO
and we'll see when we can arrange a good
time for that I also engaged in quite a
lot of tutorials some academic coaching
and a good bit of philosophical
counseling I picked up a few new clients
and you know continuing my work with
with ongoing clients if you're
interested in any of those services
again you can email me at Greg at reason
IO or go to my website reason IO calm
and you will find all sorts of really
cool information about those those
services I've been teaching my classes
my ethics class is for Marquette I
remember I got hired very last minute to
teach two sections of ethics and I threw
them together you know I've got a lot of
great material that I've been honing
over the years but I did add some some
some new wrinkles to it including
Cicero's on duties which we're studying
right now and those have been going
quite well I've really enjoyed the
discussions with the students and
developing some new resources for for
that as well I've been doing of course
the editorial work for stoicism today
which is really really ramping up as we
get closer to stoic weak and stoic on
there's a lot of behind the scenes stuff
that that has happened
didn't get at that much writing done
this month although I did have a piece
that got a lot of really nice discussion
in stoicism today on dealing with the
unduly demanding in the workplace did
some writing on her exes do you know idk
a little bit of stuff in half hour Hegel
but on the on the whole I didn't get as
much of that sort of work done as I
would like I did do some some video work
you know my throat my six half hour old
videos for the month that's the quota
that I set myself I also did an entire
series on Nietzsche's truth and lies and
an extra moral sense a lot of people
have it really enjoyed those did a
Sandler soapbox talk and of course
there's videos for all of these events
whether the face-to-face or online
events and you can check the links for
all of those below and you'll see them
I'm gonna scroll down a bit though
alright so what is coming up in October
it's really stoic month because stoic
week happens stoic on happens not
everything that I'm doing is necessarily
stoicism related but an awful lot of it
is so I'll talk first about philosophy
pop ups these are those one-hour
sometimes even longer sessions that I do
sort of announcing at the day of or for
everybody
who's not a patreon subscriber or
supporter patreon supporters find out
about when they're going to be scheduled
at the beginning of the month so they
can put them in their calendars one more
inducement to become a supporter a
little perk that I give them and this
month the philosophy pop ups are going
to be on stoicism and what is in our
control and what's not in our control
sometimes called the dichotomy although
there's some people introducing a try
Academy of control very important topic
one that there's quite often a lot of
confusion about so I will be talking
about that and then taking questions
from the audience I'll do one on YouTube
live one on Facebook live and so you
know if you if you want to know about
them in advance become a patreon
supporter if you just want
find out about them the day of check my
facebook my LinkedIn my Twitter or my
Google+ and you'll see me posting those
and I hope you can join me for that
scheduled events Thursday October 12th
at 7 p.m. Brookfield Public Library
we'll be doing our monthly you know talk
in the worlds of speculative fiction
series this time on CL more really great
science fiction writer a lot of
interesting stuff that she did in her
lifetime some of it in collaboration
with her husband Henry Kutner some of it
entirely on her own a lot of it under
pseudonyms so we'll talk about about her
and her brilliant writing Saturday
October 14th I will be up in Toronto at
stoical on presenting with my wife and
partner Andy shaaka
on dealing with difficult people in the
workplace we're leading a workshop for
stoic con participants I'm sure it's
gonna be a big draw if you're at stoic
on you know come to the workshop and and
you know you're we're gonna give you a
lot of great stuff to take home and use
and if you're not well we will be
hopefully getting good video recording
footage from it so that that's a plus as
well on Tuesday October 17th I'm back
here in the Midwest but I'll be down in
Chicago with the New Acropolis they've
invited me to come down during stoical
week and give a talk on applying stoic
philosophy in the workplace five useful
practices is one of my stock talks and
you know I sort of apply it in a lot of
different different ways anything from
you know like to our workshops to to
short punchy talks with QA afterwards in
this case it's going to last about an
hour I'm really happy to be invited down
there to do this we're also going to
have one up here in Milwaukee Thursday
October 19th
the MKE stoic fellowship which serves
the Greater Milwaukee area although we
also have some people coming down
the Fox Cities some people coming up
from the Chicagoland area and even some
people coming from Michigan from time to
time we will be having a big event here
in Milwaukee hosted at the Shorewood
Public Library on Stoicism in in the
workplace it's going to be a facilitated
discussion we're gonna take some some
you know information from the crowd
about what what issues they're facing
it's gonna be kind of a panel myself
Andy Shaka and Shawn Williams who's a
friend and collaborator from from
Marquette Monday October 23rd we have
our free webinar and that is on
Epictetus choice and character this
month around so that is open to anybody
it's going to be at 11 a.m. it's going
to run about 45 minutes we'll have 20
minutes for Q & A I'll do a little
presentation and then we'll have some
some great QA and discussion after that
that's sort of a warm-up for the much
longer seminars that I'll talk about in
a moment but before we get to that
Wednesday October 25th at 5 p.m. another
online event half-hour hagel monthly Q&A
and discussion session you know you
don't have to be a supporter of the half
hour Hagel project that is something
that's under written by the supporters
of it so anybody's got questions about
Hagel German idealism you know spin-offs
of hegelian ism come to that and we'll
we'll chat finally on October 28th we
have too much longer more intensive
online seminars this is what we've been
doing in our series we start with a
little teaser with the free webinar the
online seminars do have a tuition fee
but you also get a lot of great
resources you get a plenty of Q&A time
and they are two hours long we're going
to be talking about the same issue on
Epictetus
choice and how we form our characters
we'll be doing very in-depth on that if
you've ever wanted to understand
something going beyond the enchiridion
this is
gonna be a great set of seminars that's
all of the events so far there may be a
few others depending on you know if
people are calling me up we've got a few
podcast interviews scheduled for the
month but I don't know that there's
anything appearing this month I will be
doing a lot of work of course for
stoicism today this month gonna try to
get some some writing done as well in of
course stoicism today also in our exes
do you know antic a half hour Hegel
maybe heavy metal philosopher if I find
the time maybe policy of truth may be
partially examined life what else do we
have going on of course besides classes
I actually start a new class in addition
to the two that I'm currently teaching
an eight-week online class with Marist
College later on this world views and
values class that I've actually created
a a version of if you're interested in
my teachable Academy you can access that
very inexpensively and there's no
homework assignments or any of that but
you can you can do all the other stuff
that the students would be doing in that
class what else have we got going on oh
I should mention as well that you know
we're gonna have some family things
going on because Fall Break it takes
place so so my kids will be here and
we're gonna go out and hopefully see
some some nature out at at Poynette in
in wisconsin we're gonna take a little
trip I also do have a root canal in all
of this scheduled but you know my
dentist assures me that it's not like
the old days they can get you in get you
out and take care of all this stuff
pretty pretty quickly and fairly
painlessly so hopefully that's gonna
going to be the case a lot of video work
I'm doing this month you know of course
all these events videos I shot some core
concept videos for my ethics class on
John Stuart Mill I'll be releasing some
of those soon a lot of new videos on
Cicero's on Duty's book one I'm shooting
a ton of videos
that actually working on those this week
I'll be doing my six half-hour Hegel's
for the month I'm hoping to do some more
soapbox videos I definitely plan to do
some book review videos and I'm also
going to do some personal videos as well
those those philosophical developments
and commitments videos so a lot of stuff
going on you know I can't really wrap my
head around how much stuff that we've
got happening week after week day after
day after day so it's gonna be a very
busy time I think I won't really get a
real break until Thanksgiving although I
will have that that period of enjoying
some time with with you know family last
thing I want to put in a word about is
that we are in the process of planning
out our talks appearances all that sort
of stuff for 2018 so if you have a group
an event an institution if you have a
group an organization an institution and
you want to do an event and you'd like
me to be at your event or you'd like me
to keynote or or be the you know the
headline for the event email me Greg at
reason IO we'll get it scheduled we're
trying to fill up the calendar and we're
getting a lot of requests already for
first and second quarter I'm happy to
travel you know reach out to me and
we'll we'll definitely talk about it you
everybody who watched my videos knows
just what a range of possible topics of
discussion I have in that I'm a very you
know sort of hands-on with the audience
kind of speaker so that's that your
thing and you actually want to invite me
in or if you're interested in having me
on your podcast or some other you know
interviewing guest appearance type of
thing like I said just email me Greg at
reason IO calm and we'll get talking
about it I hope that you have a great
month I hope that everybody who's
watching this also enroll
in our stoic week course if you've got
any interest in stoicism you should
definitely do that and otherwise you
know I'll see you at some of these these
online events I'll see some of you
online and see some of you face to face
and I'm looking forward to